[Musique]
bonjour et course et oui bonjour mot
viol temps bonjour à tous les auditeurs
de martinique 1ère vous êtes le
vice-président du tout nouvel office de
tourisme de l'espace sud merci d'être
dans son caddie c'est le jeune larcher
le président de la communauté
d'agglomération qui est également le
président de la structure
mais il faut tout c'est l'espace sud a
désormais la main sur les politiques
touristiques dans l'ensemble des
communes de son périmètre
comment en est on arrivé là oui alors
effectivement ça ça mérite une
explication
tout d'abord ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que l'espace sud n'a jamais demandé
cette compétence cette compétence est
issu de la loi notre du 7 août 2015 qui
a donné obligation aux communautés
d'agglo de pci de récupérer cette
compétence tourisme que les communes
détenait depuis toujours
alors soit par soit en régie ou alors
elle avait délégué cette compétence aux
offices de tourisme que nous connaissons
on a l'impression de la façon que vous
alliez d'expliquer des choses que c'est
presque un gros fardeau qui tombe sur
les épaules de l'espace sud
alors gros fardeau
il n'y a pas de charges trop lourdes 1
on travaille pour ça c'est vrai que ça a
été une mise en place difficile parce
que c'est pas évident
avec cette loi notre de furets à mesure
les maires les élites et père d'un petit
peu de pouvoir que ce soit pour on l'a
vu l'assainissement que ce soit pour le
tourisme et autres donc il ya eu aussi
un flou sur la question de la taxe de
séjour que perçoit actuellement
voilà les communes mais également des
difficultés d'interprétation de la loi
et notamment sur les cas de dérogation
donc face à ça c'est vrai que c'est un
chantier qui était quitter l'eau nous
avons mené un certain nombre de
rencontres dans les mairies soit avec
les dgs les maires les agents nous avons
eu un séminaire sur le tourisme en
septembre 2016 en invitant tous les
agents des offices les mairies les élus
en faire nous avons préparé ce terrain
là puisque la mise en la mise en place
et est effective au 1er janvier 2017
alors ce qui est vrai pour les spas sud
est vrai également pour la casser mais
pour que le voilà tout à fait il faut le
préciser alors est ce que les communes
ont marqué des réticences malgré cette
loi notre malgré cette obligation de
rentrer dans le giron de l'espace sud
pour cela pour la politique touristique
de cet espace alors si c'est vrai que
certaines communes
on ici puisque avec la loi montagne de
2016 il était possible pour certaines
communes de déroger à ce transfert et
nous avons quatre cas particulier dans
le sud puisque bon l'espace sud ces
douze communes
nous avons tout d'abord effectivement la
ville de sainte anne qui depuis le 1er
janvier vous avez beaucoup d'autres
voient la ligne acsel massés à cette
année ce que est ce que le fait que vous
avez l'âme est désormais ce que ça va
régler le cas de cet anneau rappelle que
le maire monsieur j'ai mieux avait
dissout l'office de tourisme de la
commune voilà c'est à dire qu'il n'y
avait plus de liens contractuels entre
la ville et son office et comme je l' ai
dit en préambule
aujourd'hui si les mères qui nous
transfère leurs agents c'est pas à
l'espace sud de décider qui vient au qui
vient pas donc c'est vrai qu'il n'y
avait plus de deux situations
contractuelles entre l'office et la
ville de sainte-anne puisque sainte anne
a récupéré la compétence donc le maire a
décidé de ne pas transférer d'argent à
l'espace et sa peau mais ça ne pose pas
de problème dans la mesure où
où nous allons installer soit ce qu'on
appelle un pays tu es bureau
d'information touristique dans les
différentes communes ou alors un point
d'information puisqu'il faut savoir que
le personnel de l'espace sud est 70 sous
leur nez mais complètement alors on va
peut-être parler de la taxe de séjour
ici là où ça va se jouer
bon c'est en salle à la situation sera
réglée il ya la commune effectivement
des trois il est aussi qui par
délibération avait demandé une
dérogation au transfert en mars 2007
malheureusement effectivement le
contrôle de légalité n'a pas approuvé
cette délibération et la commune tout
naturellement à retirer sa délibération
donc la ville aura un oreiller ou raï le
maire s'est fait taper sur les doigts
par l'unef je vais pas d qui s'est fait
taper c'est à dire que comme j'ai dit il
y avait d'une interprétation de la loi
montagne qui disait que les communes
classées
touristique avait cette possibilité on a
un cas dans le sud c'est le marin qui
effectivement est dans cette démarche de
classification donc ce le transfert est
en attente jeudi si elle obtient cette
classification elle n'intègrera pas
l'espace sud est pour ces +5 lui c'est
effectivement c'était un petit peu la
même démarche que trop les trois îles et
sauf que lorsqu'il n'y a pas eu contrôle
de légalité
le maire a décidé de il a refusé de
retirer la délibération donc le préfère
donc des ferries la très dit la décision
au tribunal administratif et nous sommes
en attente de résultat donc à ce jour
sur les douze communes de l'espace sud
vous avez une commune le marin qui en
attente 5 luce on attend le résultat
d'une lime et l'administratif et donc
ils les dix autres communes
nous travaillons avec elle alors quels
seront les moyens de cette haute et on
va le rappeler office de tourisme
intercommunal
quels seront les moyens de cet outil ce
serait la somme des budgets de chaque
commune la mise à disposition de
personnel précédemment affectés aux
offices autorise comment ça va
fonctionner alors les choses seront les
suivantes
chaque commune percevait en tout cas
pour celle qu'il y avait des hôtels ou
des particuliers qui faisait de la
location saisonnière percevait ce qu'on
appelle la taxe de séjour c'est ce qu'on
voit un petit peu sur nos factures
lorsqu'on va à l'hôtel il ya une petite
ligne taxe de séjour
donc cette taxe de séjour qui était
reversée aux communes sera reversée
intégralement à l'hôte et donc à
l'office de tourisme intercommunal en
revanche et c'est le flou qui existait
on ne savait pas si
l'hôte et ip recevrez tous mais ce qui
va se passer il y aura ce qu'on appelle
la clect qui est une commission
d'évaluation des charges transférées il
très clairement synthétiquement elle va
dire quoi elle va dire bon bain telle
commune percevait 100 euros de taxe de
séjour
le coût de l'animation touristique nous
coûtait 40
c'est à dire les salaires les locaux les
différentes animations et bien si elle
nous coûtait 40 lots tehiva reversée à
la commune la différence c'est à dire 60
voire un petit peu comment ça va
soulager réticences de certaines
communes comme les trois idées avec est
pas mal d'auteurs pas mal
d'établissements me voilà non mais j'ai
envie de dire si c'était vrai que si
c'est difficile de perdre des
compétences mais dès lors qu'on a la
sécurité justement de ça ne va pas nous
coûter plus cher
je pense que bon en bonne intelligence
on travaille de concert réussir
justement à propos de bonne intelligence
tout cas très pratique il va vous
concernant directement
est ce que le maire de la commune
diamants par exemple gilbert eustache
apprécierait que ce soit laisse pas sud
qui viennent lui dicter sa politique
touristique dans sa commune qui est
l'une des plus attrayants de martinique
sur ce point alors j'ai envie de dire
non à l'exemple au hasard oui nous
n'allons pas inventé le fil à couper le
beurre
c'est là que dans les villes et j'en
veux pour preuve j'ai rencontré tous les
agents transférée la semaine dernière
dans les villes il existait déjà un
certain nombre de choses tant
l'animation touristique par un certain
nombre d'animations il ya des villes
effectivement qui organisait sa déjà
vous avez également l'organisation de
circuits touristiques pour poulets les
touristes de la ville vous aviez
également un travail fait sur les
locations
donc tout ça
viendra alimenter le projet tous ici
donc on ne fera pas sans les communes
mais on ferait de reprendre les projets
de ses concurrents exemple tout
naturellement on va pas réinventer les
choses il se faisait il existait de
bonnes choses dans les communes les
agents se sont pas de nouveaux agents ce
sont les mêmes agents qui travaillaient
dans les offices il suffit maintenant de
mettre tout ça en musique est d'avoir un
projet cohérent et global pour tout le
sud de la lentille est ce que les
rivalités politiques entre l'homme entre
les maires éventuellement le président
de l'espace sud est ce que ça peut
intervenir est ce que ça peut interférer
ce que ça peut jouer est ce que ça peut
faire capoter l'ensemble
alors je dirais que ça ne pourra pas
faire capoter et je suis optimiste en
disant que ce serait dommage que l outil
pareil où vous avez des agents qui ont
cette volonté parce qu'aujourd'hui il
s'agit très clairement synthétiquement
un touriste qui arrive à comment ça se
faisait avant un touriste qui arrive
dans une commune effectivement il ya un
office on y présente les ce qui se fait
dans la ville mais aujourd'hui ces
agents là c'est un autre métier
pour eux il s'agira de travailler avec
tous et l'agent qui avait l'habitude de
travailler sur le diamant b pourra
proposer des circuits des manifestations
qui se passe sur sainte anne sur le
françois sur les anses d'arlet donc
c'est un nouveau métier et c'est un
nouveau challenge pour ces agents alors
défis enjeux chalenge il ya ce fluide
escales de bateaux de croisière liées au
passage des ouragans irma et maría ça
représentera entre 50 et et sans escales
supplémentaires que nous n'avions pas vu
venir un sens et être sans cette
catastrophe météorologique
c'est un challenge pour vous comment
vous allez faire parce qu'il va falloir
accueillir ces personnes maintenant
alors justement ben voilà le premier
défi que nous avons et pas plus tard que
pendant ce mois d'octobre là puisque
c'est pas moins de du double de bateaux
de croisière qui
feront escale dans le sud notamment sur
les communes des trois îles et des anses
d'arlet et du marin part ça les gros
monstres les groupes paquebot qui arrive
à fort de france alors non effectivement
puisque il s'agira de deux bateaux
essentiellement d'environ 400 500
croisiéristes donc là encore nouveau
défi et j'ai envie de dire on a cette
opportunité aujourd'hui de ne pas
raisonner en termes de fils c'est à dire
qu'un office et 3 4 personnes voire
moins ou un peu plus aujourd'hui on
pourra très clairement dire bombay un
bateau qui arrive aux trois ilets
l'équipe des agents aujourd'hui c'est
environ une quinzaine de personnes et
bien c'est cette quinzaine de personnes
pourra aller justement sur la commune
des trois îles et pour pouvoir
accueillir ces croisiéristes le roller
opposé un certain nombre de circuits
touristiques dans le sud les agents des
trois ilets actuellement sur suisse
avons formés pour pouvoir vendre par
exemple le diamant d'autres communes
comme ça du jour au lendemain comme ça
en claquant des doigts
alors justement si c'était l'objet de
notre réunion de la semaine dernière et
ils sont
assoiffé de connaissances et j'ai envie
de dire c'est justement là jean deux des
trois îles et qui portera un plus à
celui du diamant et les autres et vice
versa et c'est ici en bonne intelligence
que nous allons travailler ensemble pour
que quel que soit l'âge ans qui se
trouvera sur le territoire et même au
vivier en salle et du cos est bien pour
pourra parler des autres communes de son
territoire et ses douze toute cette
richesse pour les agents et je suis
confiant là-dessus loti va booster le
tourisme
j'espère que l'hôte et il va booster le
tourisme et j'ai envie de dire comme je
le dis souvent seul on va vite mais
ensemble on va plus loin
ce sera le mot de la fin merci d'avoir
été ce matin avec nous tu sais on
rappelle que vous êtes vice président de
l'office de tourisme intercommunal de
l'espace une bonne journée merci morice
violon
[Musique]